io condivido solo titone ciao e anima
nulla delle frange più richieste che
assoluto e cioè incinta per 24 ore al
tiro speriamo bene ma sarà super
divertente sicuramente guardate il video
fino alla fine perché ci fa fare la
società d'ascolto vediamo se riuscite a
trovarli
allora come però essere città permessi
quattro ore per esso il punto su prato o
non è cosa che in realtà ho la pancia di
babbo natale oppure la pancia faccia di
irap oppure una tomba o roba insomma
ho preso una colomba pancia di babbo
natale non abbiamo provato sono super
curioso di provarla vediamo un po come
di cogeme insieme quattro gemelli 3
atlanta crisi sta gonfiando che pancione
e io non ho bisogno di questo perché io
la versione reale e tipo usciva la
spiaggia questo sembra davvero ora
spetta merlino questa la falla fa
esplodere in due secondi
si registra allora essi calde allora
praticamente la devo a vendere andare in
giro così ma sicurezza forse si può
regolare a magari facciamo un nodo
dietro allora per metterla all'altezza
giusta
[Applauso]
oh mio dio esista venga questo vede lega
diciamo che la vita non aiutano nemmeno
normale gigante che siano bene secondo
me che non sei votare più popolosa le
trecce dei tre marchi e allora in
pratica dovrà stare 24 ore incinta e
vedere come la vita con una pancia
enorme e vedere insomma poi il sor le
sofferenze delle mamme anche perché non
è semplice rimanere incinta per nove
mesi soprattutto quando la pancia in
inter persone tanto e inizia a pesare un
fatto questo ovviamente non perda se
avete non pensa che sarà più facile per
me però vedremo cosa sarà difficile fare
le cose di ogni giorno da incinta e poi
dovremo avere prova spetta a primi ma
che è diverso fare la spesa nei chip
sarà estremamente imbarazzante perché se
qualcuno mi riconosce
una cosa così il pericolo però eticità
poi il giorno dopo mi vede che non
dovete sapere durif ero nessuno di voi
mi riconosca proprio oggi mi faccio tre
ps il mondo mi riconoscete comuni the
sun tardi in giro al supermercato bube
però proprio questa volta perché nessuno
mi riconosca altrimenti penserà che sono
veramente città pronti lasciate un bel
mi piace
se volete vivere altre challenge il 24
ore e fateci sapere nei commenti se voi
siete figlioli sistemate sorelle la se
siete gemelli 1 per fratelli e due
sorelle è un lancio per la gioia al
regime da gattina silvia e tu invece io
ho un fratello e un pochino di questa
trattata dobbiamo ci dobbiamo sistemarla
meglio vero dai cambio maglietta perché
queste ricreativa tiro a berlino non
potermi vede incinta di cinque figli
berlino il trucco per farlo arrivare
subito a fare il cuore di boots di
proteste dico questo vino eccolo sta
arrivando sentito rumore buongiorno
[Musica]
ciao a tutti velino guarda un omaggio
recchino quello che hai mangiato tu come
l'anguria berlino sta dormendo dice
queste notizie shock da quando sono
sveglio troppo ingombrante testa
nonostante la falsa ingombrante li
senario marino non gliene freghi niente
confronto chiuso comodo ma non era
gestito nei commenti in italia se ne
accorgano quando sei incinta per davvero
sono sono sensibili quindi penso che lui
se ne sia reso conto che per 24 ore
dovrà provare a fare una serie di cose
da incinta una delle cose che voglio
provare a fare
castello quel periodo tutte le salire
sopra di questo detto vediamo definire
tutto questo quando sam intralcia 3
tutto bene non intralcia ha detto mi
devo buttare sulla pancia vederti
rieccola sopravvive anche con la parte
di carte ovviamente è un po un intralcio
questa farsa perché e comprate in più se
fosse cantante starebbe supportati di
otto mi dispiace un sacco per le donne
incinte che devono sopportare della
forza su nove metri neppure un attento e
500 miglia più tempo in spagna dormire
qua ed elogia e ci sono le crocchette di
berlino come voglia mi devi portare una
pizza con le fragole asi e cioccolato
parliamo estremità bene l'occhiale piano
erano cadere però la pancia del fratello
deriva stata la faccia bisogna stare
aperti è la prima parte della giornata
lino continua a dormire
non mi frega niente della mia faccia
berlino berlino guarda che ho avuto alla
spinosa fa paura montare la forza
ragazzi siamo in macchina stiamo andando
al centro commerciale e è fastidioso
anche mettere la cintura guardate qua mi
omega palazzo gigante quindi qualsiasi
cosa fare qualsiasi cosa è molto più
difficile devo dirvi che io sono super
imbarazzata che andare al centro
commerciale di uscire in pubblico perché
la pancia è enorme come potete vedere
ben più ho paura non solo che qualcuno
mi riconosca ma anche che qualcuno si
accorga che magari la pancia finta che è
ancora più imbarazzante perché pensano
ma questa caffè che si è voluta mettere
una palla finita addosso un'altra paura
che ho è che la sicurezza del centro
commerciale mi chieda ma era in gita o
stai nascondendo qualcosa sotto la
pancia stai cercando di rubare qualcosa
che lo stai mettendo nella pancia mese
decisamente il video che mi sta dando
più disagio in assoluto per fare anche
uno dei più vita uno dei più pazzi e
divertenti che abbiamo il fatto sono
veramente curioso di vedere se le
persone reagiscono in modo strano no da
vedere se è molto più difficile fare
mostre vita qualsiasi cosa appunto e
niente come potete vedere la pancia
enorme ho messo una camicetta stopria
per cercare di non mi vedo di camuffarla
un pochettino insomma per non far vedere
che troppo grande o non parte bene
troppo che tante ora vedremo come andrà
la situazione ma you decisamente solo
supera disagio quindi lasciate un mi
piace per
comportarmi siamo arrivati io mi
vergogno troppo severa lavoro enorme
[Musica]
adesso problema ok ho riacquistato
confidente vediamo le donne incinte o
nella sezione abbigliamento per bambini
ma innanzitutto maschio femmina dobbiamo
prima decidere se maschio femmina
secondo me massimo secondo me
no femmina mezzo e su più vestiti carini
vediamo un po tutti belli sono più belli
vestiti per bambini agli operatori un
mini cammino la scarpetta
[Musica]
carinissime che sia un po di del bambino
tutto finito
[Musica]
questa mattina carina
oddio queste calze di questo completino
per papig è carino 4 6 mesi
no e poi è questa 68 69 68 mesi ho 68
anni
[Risate]
piccoli
va tutto benissimo nella sezione bambini
guardate che cosa che carini antonino
campeggia minuscoli guardate queste
calze o mio dio
che tenerezza mio zio porto che prima
che scatti la nonna diritti
scarpino guardate questo capire che
carina ricomprarlo lo stesso anche se
insomma
che carino ma quanto sono bravi ma il
primo tipo è passato e mi ha guardato
male
non so se non so se tipo povera te che
devi partorire un bambino così grande
pensate che bello questo pikachu per il
nuovo film che sta uscendo di supermario
chi spesa fatta siamo tornati in
macchina io la mia parola è vitale
l'arrestato definita molto particolare
perché abbiamo tutto la spesa e poi sono
stato in giro per alcuni negozi abbiamo
visto i vestiti per bambini allora è
strano perché tutti mi guardavano tutti
mi guardavano tipo la pancia tipo oh mio
dio non so se pensavano
oddio conto e grotta oddio quanti
bambini di partorire oppure oddio perché
è mangiato quella anguria senza
tagliarla era molto strano è vero molte
persone si ricordava molte donne
ricordavano soprattutto quindi non so
sinceramente se qualcuno si è accorto
che la pancia fosse finta sicuramente si
sono accorti che la pancia e fiat è
scattato veramente stancante anche se
siamo stati lì per poco tempo e più
stupisce è davvero stancante avere la
pancia e questa è pure leggera non oso
immaginare veramente le donne incinte
che hanno la pancia che pesa pure come
fanno a fare tutto il giorno con la
pancia come può anche fare non mimetico
lo penso io
in più ho notato un altra cosa volevo
vedere se le persone erano proprio
gentili non lo sto tenevano un
comportamento diverso perché io penso se
vedo una donna incinta mi viene ad
esempio da farla attraversare farla
passare qualcosa del genere
invece no non che me lo aspetti
assolutamente soprattutto io perché non
solo veramente in città comunque quando
la mamma a casto c'erano delle persone
anziché hanno creato un ingorgo quindi
siamo tanti gli impieghi per sempre di
tempo e ho pensato se così davvero in
città sarebbe stato molto stancante toma
mi è dispiaciuto per le donne incinta
che a cui non vengono fatti questi
favori e poi stava tentando la strada
sapete che in italia
purtroppo è difficile attraversare la
strada perché non tutti si fermano non
sanno tutti molto gentili e non tutti si
fermano a far passare i pedoni purtroppo
e quindi ho pensato ad e dai ora che mi
vedono con la pancia per porta ci
faranno passare subito no siamo rimasti
lì aspettarmi che qualcuno la metto
tutte le macchie e poi abbiamo
attraversato quindi mi dispiace perché
bisogna avere più rispetto per le donne
incinte non per me perché non sono
veramente in città però penso tutte le
donne che sono incinta incinte o in
città non ti viene trovato neanche
magari se vedete appunto che c'è qualche
donna incinta in fila magari potevamo
stare avanti o se guidate
fatela traversale insomma hashtag più
rispetto per le donne zitte comunque
finora è stato veramente faticoso pur
avendo una pancia piena d'aria ora
continuiamo la nostra giornata avevo
davanti una cosa io ho detto che mi
sentivo di tokyo mi sentivo veramente un
sacco a disagio ma non per il fatto di
essere in città non c'è niente di male
per il patto che avevo paura che le
persone si rendessero conto che fa mi è
fitta e sarebbe stato un po imbarazzato
e soprattutto se raccogliamo la
sicurezza e lo sapeva perché con una
faccia finta quindi questo
ciao a tutti e comoda comoda sia deciso
l'addio the city sono a chi ha votata le
il titolo gioca ed è solo in coppa di
lega cosa che voglio provare le città e
fare qualche esercizio perché già nel
modo più difficile camminare con questa
dovra venire modo per fare qualche
gestibili prezzi berlino governo di 35
non sono impegnato a cacciarmi la cosa
anzi la zampa berlino da un pò di
stretching compensi ad essere veramente
fastidiosa
non so perché grosso ma anche perché
mista appiccicando tutta la palma così
lucido vero che nel supermercato viaggio
punto ho visto una persona che mi
guardava qua addio
mi fa un po impressione effettivamente
visto casey a berlino per plan squadra
mi rovino faccio il tuo uomo fratellino
sto cercando di morde lo studente di
quasi nuovo fratellino
nel secondo si è effettivamente più
difficile anche questo pur essendo
verona facciate scalinata che sta
facendo questo
berlino sta pensando ma che sta fa
questa ok ora proviamo a rincorrersi con
merlino vediamo quanto sarà più
difficile con la pancia è già un bel po
di vento oggi spero che si senta bene ma
abbiamo un nuovo microfono quindi
dovrebbe sentirsi un po meglio attentato
alla vita di anita da parte di berlino
ciao
no
preti come correre con la pancia allora
sì più fastidioso pur essendo leggerà
questa berrino propri diritti
bravo l'ha distrutta o corso pochissimo
modo di fronteggiare berlino
direttissimo
visto come corri sembra un cerbiatto un
daino che fai merlino che così sentito e
che cosa hai visto noi mette sibille
tutti decisamente è più faticoso perché
è ingombrante
non riesco a respirare bene adesso
svengo scherzo al tar e non mi ha
spiegato in pratica se un gatto che
viene sempre fa un gatto nero con la
puntina della casa bianca
noi lo faremo entrare in casa il
problema è che merlino li rincorre non
vogliamo che li faccia del male e quindi
rimane qua fuori
nel frattempo guardate dov'è arrivata la
pancia chigi ghiottone ciò è stato
stanca sono stanche frazzitta pd e ora
io dormo to mister b ed allora mi devi
preparare pro la pace di plastica
andò a preparare sarà di plastica
vari gli spaghetti al sugo farmi una
torta al cioccolato e ti aspetto qui
oggi facciamo torto al sugo di spaghetti
cioccolato grazie
in effetti è interessante come
combinazione di spaghetti al cioccolato
voli potremmo provarli primamente
gravidanza mi ha fatto venire fame
stanchezza quindi è ora fermo un po tu
devi portare cibo la soletta qua va bene
che l'aspetta io a domandarmi tutto il
resto
forse il cibo di pop ma quando tutto ciò
che lascia continuare
e quando un po e aspettarci può mordere
ti porto un uovo di pasqua ma voglio
cibo team di porzio cioccolato
ok
[Musica]
vasco l'importanza di avere rispetto per
per mezzi per portare tutto quello che
voglio altrimenti al bambino vengono
rivolte non lo sapevi cosa sarà in città
per conto dello stile adesso vedo di
vaccino di drago è che poi facciano
essere un vero drago d'acqua e poi
bruciati a tutti i capelli per la mia
gravidanza finisce qui e tempo di
togliere la pancia e vedere come mi
sento senso sì un po gonfiata non so
sofia bucata già sta respirando mica
oratorio o che l'ho tolta mi sento un
peso in meno
letteralmente bellissimo toglier trauma
avendo modo di leggere o la pace tutta
sudata per questa faccia e comunque non
solo come fanno davvero la cover e mamme
incinte a trasportare la pancia per nove
mesi miracolata stagno che il rispetto
per le mamme incinte esperimento è stato
super divertente per me è anche privi
tale è stato bellissimo vedere cosa si
prova per poco tempo essere un bene mi
piace se volete vedere oltre ciò nelle
24ore tipo questa consigliate sicuri nei
commenti che altre falle di
ventiquattr'ore volete vedere
e ora vi lascio 4 kb s qui cliccare per
vedere i miei altri video
cliccare su quelle proferite da imparare
indiani